as a CEO at the helm who was there for
nearly 30 years and you were to seal for
18 years until the day went out of
business and did not run out of business
that was bought from one uh by Chase
what could you have done differently as
the leader of the Hill
obviously that's a question I think
about a lot
about uh yeah you know as I said first
we did a lot of things trying to prepare
for this thing again fortunately you
know I knew housing looked overvalued
and that we ought to get prepared for it
and the like the things that we could
have done
uh that we didn't were probably along
the line of getting out of lending three
or four years ahead of that 100 percent
uh you know we had made a lot of
commitments on low and affordable home
lending to help people and the like and
uh I just couldn't bring myself to
saying we're just going to cut it off
totally and in hindsight we would have
been better off if you had just uh
dropped out of it I do think that in
Heinz I was looking back I think some of
the products and these would be the
things like we're covered in this in the
movie The uh uh big short big short that
is not those were not option arms they
were really focused on the products that
the subprime lenders were doing uh and
those were uh what 228s and 327s were
basically the interest rate was fixed
for two or three years and with the idea
that you'd give subprime borrowers the
ability to have two or three years to
improve their credit and then and then
the interest rate jumps up on them well
over time those worked okay but it never
felt like a very good product because
people would hit payment shocks and the
like and we did not offer that product
initially
and we bought a company of a very small
company called Long Beach Mortgage that
was in that and so we had some of those
but the more I looked at that I said boy
and we we eventually closed that product
down but in hindsight I wish I'd never
even gotten near it uh and and sometimes
people confuse that product with option
arms and again I don't want to be a big
champion of option arms because they are
riskier than fixed rate they worked well
for years and years but they they did
have higher losses than fixed than
traditional fixed rate but they were
nowhere near the problems of these uh
228 and 327 uh kind of low so I wish we
would never even have seen that subprime
market the other point I should have
made earlier too is that in our case the
option arms only went to Prime borrowers
that was not a subprime product it only
went to people with uh with prime FICO
scores so it the product was originally
designed okay but uh but but I think
when when uh Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac
got involved in it they lowered
underwriting standards and that product
started getting
put into the hands of subprime people
too and that that was uh inappropriate
in in looking back in uh at time but you
know I felt good that we uh on that
those raw ethics question that we always
had that at the Forefront I mean
absolute honesty integrity and fairness
we're right at the top of our values and
we led the industry in things like
adopting responsible lending principles
we wouldn't do a lot of those products
that that others would even though you
know they could make money on them and
tried to do that or tried to be as
conservative as we could on that front
but I think in hindsight the we also had
a a mission to gradually move our
Charter away from a thrift Charter to a
full banking Charter so we could
diversify away from Real Estate more and
I just didn't have time I should have
again if I'm in hindsight we would have
pushed that uh higher on the agenda and
got it done immediately but we we
started on a plan in the early 2000s it
it helped with buying a credit card
company it helped with growing our small
business and Commercial landing and the
like but I needed to make a large
Commercial Bank acquisition to make it
meaningful enough so that we could
shrink the balance of residential assets
and we we didn't get that done so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]